the Chicago area facing a two- front
battle over Biden's border crisis a
migrant surge coupled with a related
rise in retail theft in the nearby
suburb of Oakbrook Illinois authorities
say six migrants from Venezuela and
Chile stole more than $110,000 along
with merchandise from a Macy's
department store those thefts happening
in two separate incidences on the same
day Oakbrook chief of police Brian stus
says it's only part of a growing problem
in his community and he joins us now uh
Chief thanks for being with us we hear
from the mayor of Chicago about how this
has become a problem in the city of
Chicago but here you are in the suburbs
of Chicago seeing the same
thing yeah you know just to uh put it in
context Oakbrook is in dup Page County
Chicago's in Cook County we're about 12
miles Due West of Chicago um there's a
much different philosophy in terms of
policing and prosecution in Dage County
versus Cook County State's Attorney Bob
Berlin and his team charges these
offenses with burglary most times and
files motions to detain often times
those motions are denied but they're
filing those motions they're charging
these people appropriately and trying to
uh get ahead of this problem let's take
a look at what that problem has entailed
in your city of Oakbrook uh from October
23rd to January 17th like we have some
we can put up on the screen here the
number of um illegal immigrants arrested
is at
47 so I'm I'm curious Chief like what
kind of increase is that from what
you've seen in the
past it's it's a lot and it's a defin
actually it's at 55 now um in that in
that time frame and that's taxing for
any Department our department is 42
officers sworn um so that's that's
taking officers away from other
responsibilities and dedicating them uh
to our retail areas to make sure that we
keep those areas safe well what what you
just brought up retail area so what kind
of crime are we talking
about well Oak Brook has the second
largest shopping center in the state of
Illinois it's a huge economic engine not
only for our village but also for the
state of Illinois and uh with this
increase of increase in illegal migrants
coming out and committing retail thefts
and burglaries it's it's definitely uh
putting our department in a position to
where we have to respond to this and
deal with anything else that we're uh
dealing with on a daily basis I mean as
you're well aware there's no lack of
crime in the Chicago land area but to
dedicate a sign ific amount of resources
to protect these areas is is taxing for
any Police Department out of curiosity I
don't know if you have this off the top
of your head but with that with you know
55 different arrests you have a some
sample size of the illegal immigration
issue in Chicago where where are they
coming
from no they're definitely coming from
Chicago we're seeing them come out on
buses sometimes in in vehicles I mean I
mean origin originally are they from are
they from Central America Mexico where
are they from Mostly from Venezuela most
of our arrests are V Venezuelan migrants
H that's and what we're see what we're
seeing too is some of them have been
arrested by other agencies in the
Chicago land area we even had one
incident where we searched a vehicle uh
after the arrest and there was uh an ice
bracelet in the vehicle that was cut off
by the offender that was previously
arrested so this is a real problem and
uh it's you know the the effects of uh
legal migrants coming here and um
exploiting uh certain elements of this
country and not embracing it is is
certainly felt by uh agency C cities
smaller than uh Chicago and other areas
where they're where they're staying all
right Chief Brian stras thank you for
being with us this morning highlighting
this problem thank you I'm Steve duy I'm
Brian kilme and I'm Angley aart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis